what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today
Jewish girl reacts that's what we'll
call this sex so yes a Jewish girl and
boy React to what movie is this for
watching today Roxy The Prince of Egypt
The Prince of Egypt do you know what the
story is I think I think I know I think
it's probably about Let My People Go our
Exodus escape from Egypt yeah is that
what this is and then he like you know
defeated Goliath oh after eating the
Apple that gave him super powers
and Kane yeah and then people came in
and the Jews took over the movie and
music and business right afterwards
right right all started with Moses back
in the day yeah Moses is the homie man
hey leave a like yeah this is fun I have
carte blanche because I'm Jewish oh so
you can't say as much you can't mess
around like I can't this is exactly even
if I was Catholic Catholics don't like
when you make fun together oh yeah but
Jews can get away with it yeah you'd be
surprised that's true there are certain
camps where were you in 1998 that you
missed this
um probably a really
abusive situation
you were you were uh the princess your
home Prince of North Hollywood at the
time Old Testament and the Torah are
essentially the same right what we got
is the Old Testament what you got is the
old in the New Testament yeah yeah we
got the sequel yeah yeah we essentially
got half of what you have you're like
nope he guess who's back but you don't
but you don't call it the Old Testament
right so I guess it would just be the
Testament I know you really respect your
people and your culture and you really
fight for their rights they're not like
religious no so that the Jews there is
um reform conservative and Orthodox I am
reformed do things like put an orange on
my seder plate a secular Jew so okay a
non-religious Jew but the tradition
stuff is sick because it's only it's an
ethno religion ethnically I'm cool
Jewish but religiously I
believe in the people are you religious
no I grew up a hardcore Catholic though
with like the church yeah the the church
the New Testament Church uh yeah I grew
up hardcore with the confession stuff
yeah there's part of the package yeah
wow that was an altar server I don't
remember sometimes the difference
between Catholic and the other one so
that's the one with the Pope catholic's
the one you mainly see in the movies
full length three action Watcher lungs
and by the way thank you to all joined
our patreon because we've gotten so many
people joining ever since we've been
doing these moving reactions soon you'll
you'll have some solo ones here just
give you a few more in here whoa yeah
it's because I told them how sexy they
are when they join
super sexy Rejects
you don't like subtitles right
it's a musical let's find out
this is like Les Mis okay so does part
Musical
they're going hard in this opening I
wonder why they wanted to make this
movie for kids
so the story can be more accessible for
everyone I suppose this is an important
cultural story that's what Rugrats are
for though
[Music]
God you know hand-drawn animation just
gets so much more motion I love it
I have nothing I can give I'm glad she's
transitioned to English
[Music]
what was that word Deliverance Deliver
Us Deliver us if we had subtitles we
could have
[Music]
Deliver us to the promised land
so she's sending Moses in the basket
down the river
but they're not giving much of a
backstory I'm sure we'll get it
[Music]
oh cute little Moses it's a young
Charlton Heston right there
[Music]
this is some powerful music some might
say harrowing
not the hippos wow
look at baby Moses go
being protected by the seat
that is exactly how we were always
taught the story though really yeah like
the biscuit has to go through and then
they describe like the worst conditions
oh no way I totally missed that part
brother
[Music]
you open that you find it's a kid are
you like smiling like that or are you
like how much can I make off this baby
that's where my mind goes
come back someday she tracked all the
way to here snuck in
peer in on this feels like you could
have just brought the basket
come Ramesses we will show Pharaoh your
new baby brother an interesting Hair
Choice on the side like that
how'd you like your face carved on the
wall someday yes how about now
[Applause]
whoa whoa guys come on Moses admit it
you've always looked up to me yes but
it's not much of a view
[Laughter]
wow you gotta get the Jews out of Egypt
thank you
uh are they gonna ruin all this
wow turn that frown up Sunday
that feels like symbolism for Jewish
noses but that's not a Jewish note
maybe that's why it came off so easy
[Music]
I seek to build an Empire and your only
thought is to amuse yourselves by
tearing it down have I taught you
nothing is that a letterbox
the fault is mine I go did Ramesses on
and so I am responsible
responsible and do you know the meaning
of that word ramessy the theme
to understand the task for which your
birth has destined you the ancient
Traditions one damaged Temple does not
destroy centers of tradition but one
weak link
pharmacies
that you're wildly Reckless the
ridiculous you destroyed the entire town
must you be so hard on him
Moses
[Laughter]
all he cares about is is your approval I
know he will live up to your
expectations he only needs the
opportunity do you think he always
stands there hoping he is in alignment
with a statue I don't know but it is a
great shot
single-handedly you will manage to bring
the greatest Kingdom on Earth to ruin
why is it that every time you start
something I'm the one who ends up in
trouble it's interesting to have him
have a British accent like this
Classic Hollywood
you're in trouble get down here I think
you owe us an apology you might as well
oh they got along so well you care too
much and your problem is you don't care
at all oh in that case I suppose you
care a lot more than I do that we're
late for the banquet for example don't
worry guys Moses gonna care so much by
the end of this yeah they do make them
both such punks we present for your
delectation and Delight
delicious stolen from far away land
oh that's messed up we offer you this
delicate desert flower
this is very jasmine-esque yeah I feel
like she's also going to become a love
interest here
but what an introduction for a love
interest Cobra you will show the proper
respect for a prince of Egypt none
wait
like it's a human what's wrong with you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
Moses is a
twerp
and he's not gonna have a character Arch
at all in this movie he's gonna remain
that way
Moses as Royal Chief Architect awesome
he earned it by torturing this poor
woman I want that ring Loki I have that
ring
[Music]
that's my sister isn't it well
laughs
right
she tied them all up even dogs
yeah that's kind of rude
wow
I'll go ahead of the time this movie was
with how woke it is
tying up dogs come get him a woman you
know just being independent
princess
oh he's good he's gonna help her there's
a man tied up in my room
well look into it right away sir Moses
is all right I need water I have a long
journey ahead of me may God protect you
I hope it's not a sister because he has
a crush at different times back then
Roxy that's some Luke Laya
oh
sorry I'm so sorry that's her yeah yeah
I didn't expect to see you here didn't I
tell you Aaron didn't I tell you I knew
he would return to us when he was ready
is that Sandra Bullock I knew you cared
about our freedom freedom why would I
care about that because you're you our
brother oh dude that's not how you do it
she's already knew
who never told me what you you know be
careful slave she's exhausted from the
day's work not that it was too much we
we quite enjoyed it
you are not a prince of Egypt please
Moses you must believe that's enough you
were born of my mother stop it you are
our brother wow wow your highness she's
ill we beg your forgiveness please
Miriam man this is tense I
save my life from who ask the man that
man that you call Father is he Jeff
Goldblum God saved you to be our
deliverer enough of this and you are
Moses I said enough
um
you will regret this night and what is
your name again so I can tell on you
no
baby
ah this baby ears remembered bring him
all back remember
my last lullaby
wow
[Music]
that was triggering for him yeah imagine
when he gets around a hippo
that's her best joke yeah sweet perfumes
of incense and graceful rooms of
alabaster storm all I have a wanted
the singing's internal yeah I have a
sovereign Prince of Egypt had stunned
everyone
surely this is all I ever wanted no it's
not buddy come on man you know you want
to get rid of that wig
[Music]
what a zoom
whoa
what a crazy nightmare to be having
I love this animation choice
yes good hide in the plants
[Music]
people is that they are people
you know what I mean I mean as long as
he does something I think we're good
but he's only gonna do something because
he finds out it's his people
maybe it's just a catalyst to change
[Music]
wow is he like having like a vision of
all this right now I don't know
[Music]
foreign
stop running from the true history
I really did like that sequence
especially doing it through that
animation style that's how people
dictated history back then
[Music]
oh they really do little penises on all
of them you see that it's the first
scene
most harrowing shot of the whole movie
so far like wow the roast yourself
Father tell me you didn't do this Moses
sometimes
just knows for the greater good
grief is must be made oh he was paying
by it apparently
how did Moses not know about this how
would you even know
sacrifices they were only slaves oh I
think he was just completely ignorant to
how slaves releasing this depiction of
how slaves are yeah however they were
treated just as people
is this where you found me so everything
I thought everything I am is a lie now
you're just adopted dude this is your
whole
[Music]
send you a blessing you don't ask why it
was said
I actually liking the musical numbers
they they really carry the narrative
forward instead of just being fun yeah
they are very serious I understand why
they're not like catchy catchy
sing-alongs you play in the family yeah
although I have heard a lot of them I'm
here
[Music]
there's nothing that we can do oh
stop here it is let's go Moses come on
Moses
so is this leave that man alone
there it is
oh damn
um who did this a bear it was Ramses
can they tell if that's Moses down there
I mean everyone up there can yeah up
here but down there they say who did
that that guy up there
Moses can't you see brother
I can't stay here any longer Moses no
all I've ever known to be true is a lie
I'm not who you think I am damn you're
Roxy now he just keep seeing it like did
you always start caring because he's
Jewish got her really stuck in my head
it's tough to oversee
[Music]
oh they really did get along they were
effing things up all over town I know
man they're like Bonnie and Clyde but in
a sibling way okay I feel like there's a
lot of other references maybe I couldn't
pull it at the time I still can't pull
it now I can't think of one even right
now
[Music]
good pull he did it thank you I think
that's what we were going for
foreign
the detail of hand-drawn animations is
so much more enticing I'm gonna get so
much heat for this but this isn't Disney
is it it's DreamWorks oh it's DreamWorks
yeah but there are parts of it that
remind me of like a cross between
Aladdin and Pocahontas
that man is how are you gonna prove to
anybody or you
[Music]
wow that was a fast
wow
laughs
your eyes would be burned out
oh
she looks like a plant
ouch
oh oh
I think he wanted to die
wait wait
I do like the angle that we came to the
realization of everything from being a
spiritual journey that he had in his own
head you're just trying to make excuses
for him yeah it's really just a selfish
guy
[Music]
time to kill more people Moses killing
is not the way Greg it becomes one of
The Commandments aren't these your
camels
yeah get that Marvel body shot
not well made not well made he's been
cleansed in water and I just got that
trying to get the funny man out of the
way oh what are the odds is she gonna
not recognize him I think she's gonna
know exactly who he is I don't think so
[Music]
[Applause]
bummer good one
he helped you escape he also humiliated
her in public yeah that's true that's
some Stockholm thing that I was saying
no not there how do you get out
ladies who've cleaned every inch of me
not every I was wrong it went for the
buy I'm excited for this part of the
movie yeah when it finally focuses on
the
I'm doing good yeah she'll be my
honored guest my father Jethro high
priest of Midian
oh yeah get to know your people let us
give thanks for this Bountiful food soak
your thanks for the presence of this
Brave young man whom we honor here
tonight so because they know what he did
yeah I believe so first you rescue
Sephora from Egypt then you defend my
younger daughters from break-ins
how about those two things a single
thread in a tapestry though its color
brightly shine you can never see its
purpose in the pattern of The Grand
Design how's the dance moves yeah yeah
we've changed you're enchanting
does it think it's more
yes
look at your life through Heaven's eyes
[Applause]
ah this is what you guys do every
Hanukkah no he's a high priest they're
not even part of the tribe I know those
things
my shepherd boy is greater than the
richest king
or is it the beginning of a new and
brighter birth
he was cleansed in the well the answer
will come to him who tries to look at
his life through Heaven's eye there's
always this like Hakuna Matata walking
across that happens in these movies and
this is this chance with me
you know the moves
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the actual dance moves yeah
you're getting married
[Applause]
I love that this is eyebrows are brown
still
[Applause]
oh look at him having a great life
oh
they're married now I love you is it
true yeah just see what happened they
just got married well there was a white
whatever but I didn't know it was the
end of like it happened very fast guy
I was gonna say where's the bush is this
less of a bush and more of a more of a
Tweaky plant in the in the woods we're
gonna do an animated Burning Bush you
couldn't make it more bushy
meat
wield the fire warrior
Yahweh I am that I am
and if I wasn't then why would I say I
am
everyday I I am the god of
Abraham Isaac and and Jacob all juice I
have seen the oppression of my people in
Egypt
so I have come down to deliver them out
of slavery get to work Moses and so unto
Pharaoh I shall send
you
man imagine the pressure I was The
Prince of Egypt the son of the man who
slaughtered their children you've you've
chosen the wrong messenger how can I
even speak no that's why you're the
right messenger
who made the death the mute the seeing
or the blind did not I now go I am full
of love
hey I'm sorry I had an I didn't mean to
yell at you Moses Pharaoh will not
listen so I will stretch out my hand
and smite Egypt with all my wonders
take the staff in your hand Moses with
it
you shall do my wonders I shall be with
you Moses if nothing for nothing that
would be the craziest like if that's you
I don't think I'd tell anyone we'll get
it really hard for people to believe you
on such a thing
[Music]
the dad's dead already right now right
premises it's so good to see you excuse
me uh your majesty
this man committed a serious crime
against the gods yet the law clearly
states the punishment for such a crime
death we hesitate to say Be Still he
would be killed for murdering a slave no
he didn't murder the slave he murdered
the person hanging the slave over oh
yeah yeah that's right I pardon forever
all crimes of which she stands accused
he is our brother Moses
Prince
my God this is real like Donald Trump
situation not to make this religious
video political guys
you know I am a Hebrew and the god of
the Hebrews came to me he commands that
you let his people go you could read a
book on communication on how to handle
this behold
the power of God awesome
very well Moses I'll play along
give this Snake Charmer our answer
wait what are they able to do stuff too
oh okay I thought they were just like
casting out the line by the power of raw
mute
[Music]
really working hard I went up the snake
trick huh
[Music]
I mean
you're playing with the big boys now
playing with the big boys now oh that's
pretty
stop this foolish Mission pick up your
silly poop boy you're playing with the
big boys
they just have these theatrics ready to
go
oh
catchy song there are a lot of Disney
Animation flourishes here for sure you
know this song oh yeah look what do you
see a greater Egypt than that of my
father
that is not what I see
you have
written little freedom
[Music]
oh he's making it official
oh he's got cat eyes I did not know this
God neither will I let your people go
that is the opposite of the song
they let that Easter egg on for us early
how does it feel when you get struck to
the ground when did you start caring
about slaves was it when you found out
that you were one of us yeah oh wow
God saved you from the river he saved
you in all your wanderings and even now
he saves you from the wrath of pharaoh
no
you're always getting a pass
so don't you abandon us
foreign
man you got some tricks up your sleeve
is it part of the traditional story that
or Moses would do like one of these
Godly acts that the Egyptians would come
back with something else like oh there's
my snake trick all right well let me one
up your snake trick and show you how to
do this yeah that is part of it okay I
don't know about the like theatrics of
the things coming in from the walls and
all that but yeah let my people go bring
him to me
great music
Moses
[Music]
this is when he walks on water that's
what Jesus does he's gonna throw this in
there the red blood
yeah because I was thinking about Moses
parts of seas but that's when they're
leaving that's what Jesus does good
point good point I mix up my eyes
[Music]
I'm going back to the boat instead of on
the land
straight the superior might of our God
by the power of raw
that's not the same thing
he turned a whole river
abandon this for like futile Mission
Moses I've indulged you long enough this
must now be finished it's just not the
same thing well he must be an idiot
microwave food your home
Freedom with one word
Pharaoh can take away your very lives
get to the good part yep but there is
one thing he cannot take away from you
your Judaism your faith
that one guy's like what does that get
information it's just like sulking
see this is what they can't come back uh
you never know man they pull out a bunch
of crazy earlier
oh they're gonna show us all of them at
once
the Locust one man oh there it is once I
called you brother once I thought the
chance to make you laugh was all I ever
wanted
thank you
come on Ramesses you got to pay
attention man they're like showing
Ramses oh look we do the same thing yeah
Devastation how it tortures me inside
huh I never looked at it from that point
of view that this would probably paint
Moses as well just to do this to the
Egyptians
[Music]
man when the visuals go dark it's pretty
impressive you who I call brother
wanted he just wants one thing man
[Applause]
[Music]
that he's in red and green
um Ramesses you want me to
let your people go yeah yeah it's pretty
easy get different people I remember the
time you switch the heads of the Gods of
the temple of Ra that was funny you were
there switching heads right along with
me I didn't do that oh yes you did you
put the hippo on the crocodile and the
crocodile on the Falcon don't reminisce
guys oh that was Furious you were always
getting me into trouble
this is the story of Greg and jabby Coy
right here
the dog it's about to get a lot darker
for you kid isn't that
cause no Kingdom should be made on the
backs of slaves
something else is coming something much
worse than anything before let go of
your contempt for life before it
destroys everything I don't know if he
knows sounds like you know
I think it's time I finished the jaw
Ramesses and there shall be a great cry
in all of Egypt
such as never has been or ever will be
again
[Applause]
there it is
you bring this upon yourself but
Ramesses is the firstborn
and Ramesses son take a lamb and with
its blood
Mark the little and posts of every door
that's what you see on the door here
before you enter I shall pass through
the land of Egypt and smite all the
firstborn
that's not you hardly gonna do this I
will pass over you
and the plague
shall not enter okay so now he
definitely knows
freak over here whole movie I've been
like how are they gonna do this scene oh
my God
literally first Contact
wow what a fascinating visual yeah
interesting choice that's coming from
the sky oh
oh it's like an uh Apparition kind of a
presence
fear
whoa
so it almost visually like takes it
takes their breath yeah
that is haunting cool sounds
is that Ramesses in the Sun
uh yeah it's confusing though as
Ramesses not the firstborn
he is but that only one after the
children like under 18.
it's legal age you
mission
oh oh yeah and then he changes his mind
bro
spoilers
[Music]
and that is conflicting I remember like
read this or heard the story or read it
it was always like yeah most one in
there did his thing right but you're
actually seeing how much of a toll this
took on him
[Music]
we are not afraid
although we know there's much to fear
there can be miracles
when you believe are you doing on this
yeah
this was the this is another Banger in
this time of fear when prayers so often
proved in vain hope seemed like the
summer first to swiftly flown away
they're great songs God who knows
Miracles
you can achieve
that's awesome they bring that actual
language
[Music]
it's the word language
but he's about to try to stop them that
jerk just let him go enough is enough
let them go
strong like attainable way for children
to get the story but what do you feel
like Bare Bones for sure what do you
feel like though is like the main lesson
of this for kids don't enslave people
yeah I suppose some kids need to be
taught that
[Music]
I don't think we're actually gonna get
to the Commandments in this movie Are We
I think we're just gonna part the seas
foreign
it's not gonna work and then we're gonna
end the movie
right there
[Music]
oh wow
like why would you go after them knowing
what just happened I mean he never
learned a lesson man I have nothing else
to lose
[Music]
yeah
he accidentally turns it to blood first
sure
[Music]
wow it's beautiful visual Aquaman three
all right I believe
Aaron your real brother
no one's even pushing must be freezing
in there
[Music]
look at the fish that's that was sick
looking oh that's really cool I like
that best aquarium ever
me too
man that would be awesome to see
you're gonna you think that God's gonna
be chill with you going in there after
everything he's shown you
why
leave it be my dude
[Music]
get that foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
horrible way to die he is like the
greatest failure
foreign
motions you must feel in a moment like
that you can feel a few things at once
but relief has to be top of the list oh
yeah
come on gather around here are the
Commandments
no way
I think we got to get to in some way at
least a post-crediting
[Laughter]
I thought he did die right
because they're off
curse it be thy name
Ramesses will return
2024. goodbye brother
ah and then they were free then
eventually they all grew very negative
we were free for like a hot sack we get
enslaved real quick again
[Music]
post credits let's hear credits that
we're gonna reserve it
[Music]
is that satisfying enough for you that
moment like if you're a kid you have no
idea what just happened yeah no it's
literally like a postcard scene
[Music]
oh three people directed this man I mean
I feel like the movies made for all
kinds of Camp these kind of movies of
uh of When You Believe by Mariah Carey
that's awesome I will get through my
voice to men also this is that's crazy
who would have thunk it this song right
now the postcard is ever that's her
version of it
um the
the the
SE kind of movies are made for people
who know the story
and for also the meant to like introduce
you if you don't know the story
and yeah I mean to me I was a kind of
got what I expected going into it did
you to me I did yeah definitely I mean I
I think it's a I feel conflicted for a
couple different ways I I reasons I
think that they did a very good job with
this
but it's like I I wonder when you're
talking about who's who's supposed to
get what from this like if this is what
do you get from the story itself the
actual story
the story that I know yeah yeah what did
like what what are the lessons that I
took when I first learned it kind of
thing
um yeah definitely I think that like you
hit the nail in the head obviously like
you nobody owns anybody and you're not
like just because you're in a position
of power doesn't mean you should use it
for evil
um and you're not nobody's expected to
do anything for you like and then from
the religious standpoint you know the
actual element of God will be there to
help you out and that's also the like to
me the the Journey of this has always
been like the build up to the tenure man
like totally I think for me and you and
tell me if I'm if I'm mistaken but like
as two seconds uh as two non-believers I
don't know if you call yourself secular
um but I believe uh I'm one of those
people when I say like I'm
I've really it's a very La thing to be
like I'm spiritual not religious but
there is I have a big spiritual sense in
the way of like I do believe
uh and like
let me just like formulate like most La
kind of things like a law of attraction
kind of thing like to me like that's
that Universe yeah yeah I believe in all
that and uh and and I so I do believe in
like energies and all that jazz right
um and I and I mean that full-heartedly
uh but yeah do I
necessarily but but I really respect
people's religious beliefs I really do
all things considered I do
um well I think that that maybe you feel
differently about this but I so I would
call myself agnostic which essentially
means who the hell knows
um I have no idea like how how could I
possibly know is how I feel and my mom
also I also ride that line I'd say so
like I don't know if there's a afterlife
like why would there be I don't
understand what that means yeah I don't
know like I think that's like it does
take a level some level of arrogance to
pretend that anybody knows yeah um which
I don't so I don't really pay attention
to I've read the Bible before
um I don't really like new testament too
we you want to know something really
interesting we read it in my AP
journalism class wow in high school
um holy crap that's crazy it was
interesting like as a as a piece of
literature I suppose yeah whatever it
was interesting but
um I so I pay attention in stories and I
think some of the stories are just
brilliant with great messages when it
comes to the religious aspect of it it
doesn't affect me as much so it does
kind of push these stories partially
lose me when we are talking to a bush
and it's not your inner voice it is god
um who's doing these things that
couldn't be done you know
so I I am I am curious like the message
for little kids if you're not a
religious little kid what is the
takeaway versus if you are is it like
you said God will guide you no matter
right
well I think also the message of
standing up for the right thing as well
like to me a you know
I think they made a movie about Harriet
Tubman I haven't seen this movie but I
love The Story of Harriet Tubman when
they did call her like one of her
nicknames was Moses and she herself had
had a vision
uh to go and like help out slaves and
save them and stuff you know Harriet
Tubman yeah of course I know Harry some
people don't
um oh gosh and so like to me I'm like oh
there's no judgment on the people who
don't but yeah yeah but but to me I'm
like no that's a beautiful story of
someone who really felt that God
communicated to them and they had to go
save that so to me I'm like yeah I was
communicated for her to what she needed
to do as opposed to like Moses obviously
isn't sending locusts and boils and
blood in the water like that's coming
from God right but he's still
challenging his whole identity and
upbringing that he had and then what he
called family and having to go against
that like the movie doesn't strongly go
into that side of it but I can imagine
from a cycle like I was appreciative of
seeing the uh
uh the slightly different shades of of
when he was like oh yeah I didn't ever
think of how this could be hard for
someone like Moses because at the end of
the day this is where he grew up this is
his family and he's helping to he's
aiding at the very least and burning it
all to the ground I think that that's
very relevant today for sure like
especially with the strong political
world that we're living in yeah to
develop your own beliefs that are not
your family's beliefs can be very
challenging for people absolutely and I
think that that wrong true here it did
bother me more than I expected I know he
laughed about it during this but like
how much Moses in this depiction
is blind until it's relevant to him and
I know that a lot of people are like
that but I I I'm so glad they they
verbalize that out loud because that so
shouldn't be the message for children
yeah like you know
um and then they came for me like that
you can't just support people who
deserve to be supported yeah when
they're your people
yeah no I full heartedly granted I never
even looked at it from that angle until
you said it and I was like she's so
right and then I couldn't stop seeing it
at the movie pointed out like okay so
it's intentional yeah it was like Aaron
right he was just like what until yeah I
was like way late into the movie you
were a slave yeah but it was uh it was a
purposeful choice I guess to depict it
that way
because yeah I mean
I think the movie itself was I thought I
think there's a lot like from I'm
looking from like the perspective of
it's a 90s animated movie and at the
time to do it I imagine took it's kind
of a bold move for to do like a kid like
an animated movie and then two at times
not
uh uh like you have to find the level of
Restraint of like how dark can we go but
we can't go too light-hearted or else
then
it's kind of like taken away from what
the story is All About and I thought for
the most part to make like a family film
that is except Like A Accessible family
film for this story like while some
stuff might get a little bit lost in the
messaging
I think that's important I can't make a
like a freaking Schindler's List out of
this guy you know what I mean absolutely
I'm super with you I speaking of loss in
the messaging though
and I feel like I have a good grip on
this story mostly I am confused about
what happened with his wife's family I
don't know I don't know any of that yeah
like it makes you want to do a deep dive
of like I know we had kids and but
I don't know any of it so they're living
in the
um
uh in hiding in the desert and they are
who like were they slaves that escaped
were they um Egyptians that escaped like
what is with the high priest situation
being her dad like are they running
their own society and then when we see
that they leave
um or when we see them on the other side
of the water when she he's holding a kid
presumably his so we know that she gets
out the kid gets out but like where was
the rest of the family
um or that I want to call it a tribe I
don't know what they but like that other
Society Group whatever and what what who
was that that's the part where I'm like
okay I have a big hole in whatever this
story is yeah
you can easily look it up can't we okay
I mean I thought like Voice work though
still while I'm looking this up it was
like A-list celebs yeah I thought that's
Val Kilmer yeah I thought he was great
um I thought it was wonderful uh Jeff
Goldblum haven't heard him be so serious
in so long Michelle Pfeiffer who is
Michelle Pfeiffer that's the uh
um girl
the hobby wifey
it's fun talking about this with you
because this is like akin to when you
watch a comic book movie and you know
the source material yeah it's like
breaking it down yeah I but I don't know
enough
or anything okay let's see do you
remember her name yeah Zapora so it's
the wife of Moses and
um she was voiced by Michelle Pfeiffer
who did both her speaking and singing
wow great job with the singing
uh
who is she in the Midian
is the daughter of role and the priest
of Prince of Midian
this shouldn't be so hard to figure out
yeah
and the Torah
zipporah was one of the Seven Daughters
uh
um
okay
while the Israelites and Hebrews were
captured in Egypt Moses killed an
Egyptian who was striking Hebrew for
which uh offends Pharaoh sought to kill
Moses Moses
let's see
this all stays in the video but is she
[Music]
what okay
yeah is she in Israelite or what is her
background
priest of midians let's go to the actual
Source material here
the Wikipedia or the Bible Midian
minion is uh uh Western in the Hebrew
Bible in Quran uh Northwest Arabian
Peninsula
uh okay according to the Book of Genesis
the midianites were the descendants of
Midian who was the son of Abraham oh
yeah
so she was a descendant he was a
Scientologist
huh
consider her different than now let's
just watch Roxy and Greg read it
themselves
random things about median culture
yeah
um I might have to look more in there
all right yeah just I'm gonna have to
look more into her because like who is
that and how how did they get out of
being enslaved
uh they just went really far away
[Music]
they had to escape and they won't really
I don't know I don't know that part of
the story me neither
it was interesting when they decided to
include it
oh yeah you got to have the love angle
and it was a motivating factor for him
if that is how it went in the story
itself I I so I presume
um because yeah they're I mean there's
so much more that happens after they ask
they get to the prom like I skipped past
a lot that got to the Ten Commandments
and then even after the Ten Commandments
and you know for the family so I'm like
yeah you keep a focused on the main
message of the main part of the story
because there's some like dark stuff
that happens like you mentioned now they
become they they go back to being slaved
yeah yeah
um and then not and then again and then
not and then again and yeah I still have
multiple holidays to get to we haven't
dealt with Passover yeah we haven't
gotten to anything so come on they
haven't even done like uh yeah
I haven't even done a Hanukkah movie
it's almost as if there should be one I
know maybe a romantic comedy that's what
I'm thinking uh but yeah but I think
like over when I when I try to
recontextualize it in my head of
like oh yeah I didn't even know about
the musical numbers you barely knew all
of them but I thought they were great I
thought they were beautiful is it weird
to know something and you don't know you
know where you don't have a question
where it's from I have no idea how I
know that happened when we were watching
trolls
yeah I was like I was just dance
yeah yeah totally if you were a kid
watching this do you think you would
have enjoyed it
I'd imagine so I feel like I would need
to know but I also feel like back then
I don't know what it's like for kids
growing up now but I feel like back then
it was much more like a Christian it
still is but it was much more of like a
Christian dominant America now like the
media is like people make fun of it like
a religion all the time now and talk
against religion all the time at least
when I was growing up maybe it was just
because I grew up in like within
religion I feel like it was really like
not cool to do that on media and so I
think like it was really predominant
like now
like this is DreamWorks made for
everyone and granted it's a story of
Moses and it's been told a bazillion
times uh so it's not it's not the same
as like one of those you know just
exclusively produced Christian movies
that like Christian audiences flock to
like I found one of those uh but I like
but I don't know if um I feel like
there'll be a lot of things I did I
wouldn't understand if I just didn't
actually know the story because a lot of
it is treated in that way like you kind
of need to know it but why is he
carrying those stones at the end yeah
what is what is that to encourage
um but you know like this this story of
someone who who did go against his
family uh what he grew up with and it
was it was a tall order for him you know
like he he ran away from it and he had
to face his fears so there are Shades in
there but I think overall this is like a
I want to call it a cute family film but
it's a
I think it was a little bit more
respective in certain areas and and a
little bit more Vivid with this
animation espresso than I actually
expected it to be I'm totally with you
on that the music really helped I know
we were joking in the beginning like I
don't know how they're gonna make a
musical but it was like it's so
important that this was had music in it
I actually drove the narrative yeah yeah
it would have been a little stale
otherwise yeah I mean for kids let's go
on it adds a bit of it actually helps
for a good medium yes to not because
because I have moments really like they
got to be a little bit comedic it's
animated movie
um but it was so jarring if it was like
just pure drama and then Super comic
like like a super funny moment and so
the the music helps as a good transition
uh for those moments but yeah I think
the music is great I know you were
concerned about how we were going to
kill the firstborn and they did a great
job yeah they really do they killed
those firstborns so well that's silence
but with the likes
really good it does make your heart like
kind of stop for a moment there's a
little bit it is like a soul-sucking
moment yeah you feel it in the You Feel
It In the Land
here this is the land no like the
atmosphere throughout the land yeah oh
of uh that like sucking the air out of
the room literally yeah yeah
it's a good way to put it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
how do you feel to be sitting with the
chosen person
feel honored
I don't think no other people have
reacted to this I don't think anyone's
gonna get a discussion about this
the way we're talking about an
interaction okay well what people say
right you might have had to sit through
some weird jokes from Roxy and correct
throughout what you got to this fire
like they're having a real talk about
this movie right now yeah we did yeah he
did
um I I dug this
I enjoyed it I I overall enjoyed it it
was it was a it was a Brisk brisk uh
Cliff Notes version of the book of
Exodus what is it called in in the in
the Old Testament
Exodus and not in the Old Testament
Exodus and um uh oh my God what's your
what's your book called that's what it
is is it called the Old Testament yeah
The Testament
Judaism yeah no that's what we that's it
I thought it was called something else
it's called Exodus
um yeah I I don't know what other thing
the lesson of Exodus God is Not simple
but he does keep his promises
wow okay
I would say I don't want people to say
that about me
yeah it's one thing I could give about
Greg he ain't a simple guy but he keeps
his promises just like God that's pretty
good
uh I guess it is called Exodus all right
well guys what do you think about the
Prince of Egypt ah here it is shemat
that's why I've texted you oh um that's
uh I think the Hebrew word for Exodus
Maybe
that's what I was looking for that might
be it is that what that is I guess so
it's in quotes here
um
cool
word dope dope dope dope dope all righty
I still know my whole tour portion you
want to know it yeah why not we're at
the end it would take literally 30
minutes but I can give you uh the first
part episode
[Laughter]
than now
foreign